[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so on the guest line we've got
anthony gonzalez obviously a lot of you
remember him started ohio state first
round pick with the colts played in the
league for a while
now he's a congressman from his native
ohio
and he is introducing an nil bill
national legislation for name image and
likeness
anthony or i see i want anthony
congressman
gonzalez it's ross tucker thank you so
much for coming on the show
thank you for having me anthony is
perfectly fine i was just going to ask i
was going to ask
no they're giving me the head nod so do
you get a
you know you don't get offended when
people don't call you congressman
no i i just there's a lot worse things
people call me so i'm i'm fine with
with anything um but uh no my first name
is
is preferred i think it's too formal i
mean we're just
we're representatives we shouldn't be
formalized like that in my opinion
all right well i like that anthony
because i was going to ask you i was
curious
if when you're around other congressmen
if it's like
the medical scene in spies like us where
you're like
congressman congressman congressman
congressman congressman government is it
like that or not at all
thank god it's not this place is broken
in a million ways but not quite like
that
okay good all right speaking of broken
anthony a lot of people feel like uh the
college football
model as it relates to student athletes
has been broken
for quite some time and you're the one
actually doing something about it so
i've read a little bit about it i know
you're all over this um i'm pretty
familiar with name image and likeness
but i want you to actually explain
the bill that you are trying to get past
what does it really say
so it does a handful of things our goal
is to extend the economic right which i
think is a natural right every single
person in this country has it except for
the college athlete as far as i know
maybe some people don't but as far as i
know it's just college athletes excluded
so we're going to extend that right but
we're going to do it in a way that
preserves college sports so what does
that mean
that means having restrictions on
recruitment so i don't think you know
you should have boosters in high schools
telling kids they're going to pay them a
whole bunch of money to come to xyz
school
so there'll be penalties that prevent
that from happening
but but also on the same side of that
we're going to have some parity in there
to make sure that the kids are
getting the same opportunities that some
of the universities do
and just preserve the system as we know
it and i think it'll work for everybody
i think it'll work for college football
but i think it'll work for my wife as a
college swimmer i think it would help
her she'd be able to teach swim lessons
now so
um just the basic premise is let's do
one national standard
not 50 states uh with different
standards which is what we have right
now
um but let's have one national standard
let's preserve recruitment let's
preserve the system it's a great system
and move forward well so the the one
standard nationally is absolutely the
way to go i would like to think that the
ncaa
is backing you and supports that part of
it because if it's state by state that's
an absolute mess
i guess what i don't understand anthony
is how do you prevent
the recruiting part of it like how do
you prevent ohio state
or alabama or whoever saying to a 17
year old 16 year old hey
part of the scholarship offer is we'll
also guarantee you
25 000 a year name image and likeness
i don't understand how you combat that
well you make it a federal crime
so i mean there's going to be it would
be a federal crime to do exactly what
you just said
uh which means that the person could be
criminally or civilly liable
the individual uh and the university
could be on the hook for that if it's
directly
tied to the university so i think you
know my
the thing i keep saying is let's extend
the right and if people abuse it in the
recruitment process
then you got to bring the hammer down on
them there has to be real teeth there
can't just be a small penalty and so
we're going to
have that in our bill as well but look i
mean it's like anything there's going to
be people who are going to try to work
around that
and there's going to be people who try
to game the system so the best we can do
is be very clear on what's legal and
what's illegal
and make sure that there's penalties in
place so okay so
you have some penalty in place if they
use the
nil if they have an nil guarantee or if
they have na il
enticement when their recruits uh you
know there's something i talk to i have
a recruiting business go big recruiting
so i talked to a lot of college coaches
about this
the question is what will the level of
involvement be
for the colleges themselves and the
coaching staff
or are they completely out of it it you
know
am i just saying to a penn state player
i live in pennsylvania am i just saying
hey
i'll give you 5 000 bucks to tweet this
or am i going through the program
so someone's monitoring it so you'd have
to go through the program i mean that's
the
the general idea um and one other
thing worth mentioning the coaches in
the universities they will not be
providing these opportunities now what i
suspect will happen
and i hope happens is they'll feel the
responsibility to make sure that the
kids
are doing legitimate opportunities and
you know have help with things like
paying taxes i mean when when we were in
college
i never paid we didn't pay taxes because
we didn't have this stuff
so they're going to have to all of a
sudden mature on some of these
just sort of basic adult activities like
paying taxes and managing money
i hope the universities will help with
that but with respect to providing
nil opportunities that would be illegal
under our bill this is going to be the
kids and their agents or representatives
managing that on their own with the ncaa
you know providing some oversight and
then congress stepping in if there's a
violation of the law itself
talking with congressman anthony
gonzalez from ohio the former colt and
ohio state
wide receiver okay so they will have
agents or representatives that was going
to be one of my questions
is there a limit or is it sky's the
limit
uh sky's the limit i mean i i any limit
that we put in place would feel
arbitrary to me so
um you know it's let's open up the right
let's allow for it
uh and you know i think it'll be managed
correctly i just
fundamentally believe that these kids if
they have the right representation
inside of sort of the support bubble
that exists
at a at a major college major university
uh that they'll be able to handle it i
just believe that
but i guess i don't understand anthony
how you stop and maybe you're not
supposed to
have yourself again you went to ohio
state's why i'm using the example
there's a car dealership in uh oh in
columbus
and they give every guy it's a big
booster he loves ohio state football
he gives every guy 50 grand a year
to sign autographs one day even though
he's not really getting a return on the
investment
it's not really a business proposition
for the guy
it's just boosterism is that totally
legal and fine
or is that a problem no that would be a
problem so again it's
it would depend on the individual
circumstance
right but anything that looks like
inducements
and sort of not fair market value which
you're describing
uh that would run a file but if it's
what would you know be termed sort of a
legitimate enterprise where it's
hey you know you're going to do this
radio show every week for
10 weeks and we're going to pay you x
dollars per radio show
um you know that's that would be in in
the legitimate category
um and you know then they could go
forward with that
the other thing i'll say is you know
where where you draw that line i think
is probably the most interesting
question
and admittedly you know you can't i
don't believe we can draw it in congress
so what we're going to do is just
provide the right we're going to create
create a commission
that studies it for two years and then
reports
back to congress saying hey here are the
tweets you need to make here's
some of the changes in the meantime the
incidental and the institutions
themselves
will manage the answers to the questions
that you're asking about you know what's
a legitimate
endorsement opportunity versus what's
just pure pay to play
um that'll be legislated uh by them and
and then reported back to us
and we'll tweak the law if we have to
what's the timeline like you know
like in other words how soon could you
get it passed and how soon could it be
enacted because i think
correct me if i'm wrong aren't there
some states where it should be legal
soon
yeah so this is why we need one national
standard so
mississippi and florida their laws go on
the books in july
so if you're a student athlete in the
state of florida or mississippi
you can start doing nil as of july 1st
um
but if you're in any of the other 48
states you can't so that's going to
create a chaos environment
and so we need something i would argue
we need something in the next couple of
weeks or months um but congress
being what congress is my sense is we
won't get something until
i would say end of this year at the
earliest uh
and and it could bleed into next year
but i do think we'll get it done in the
next
call you know 12 months from today i
think we'll get it done
awesome and the other thing you got
going i saw somewhere you're also
um part of ohio trying to legalize
sports betting right
no i'm so pat mcafee asked me that
question
um i'm so i'm not i gave a
an analysis of where that bill is the
state is going to do it
it's just a matter of when so similar to
nil but that's ohio state house stuff
i'm
united states congress so i i stay out
of their business they don't want me
poking around in it
and uh and it works well that way but i
think they'll get it done
okay yeah that makes sense you're you're
uh a congressman you're not in the state
of ohio
uh that makes perfect sense anthony this
was awesome
man i really really appreciate it are
you liking it are you loving it
i do so you know it's a crazy job as you
can imagine
um but look every day i get to wake up
and and try to think of ways to make the
country better i mean that's
like what could be better than that and
the i always say it's i like it more
than football because
you know that the goal is bigger and
more profound there's something cool
about waking up every day and trying to
win super bowls like that's
a pretty awesome thing um the only thing
better than that that i found
professionally is this
where you get to wake up every day and
try to make the country better you got
to deal with a lot of garbage
in the meantime but but you still get
the opportunity
so it's uh it's an amazing honor uh and
i i do love it
are you by far the best athlete of the
senators and congressmen
i'd like to think so
i'd better
i feel confident saying that i'm
probably the best athlete how good of a
cover guy is biden
you know i i don't think get him in his
back pedal i don't think he's
he's doing much no
anthony thank you so much man i really
appreciate it very informative stuff
thank you thanks for having me all right
there he is congressman anthony gonzalez
from ohio former colt and ohio state
receiver